hepinize merhaba öncelikle
2005 yılında Amerika'da Stanford
Üniversitesi'nde 50 yaşlarında bir adam
öğrencilerle sohbet ediyor onlara
tecrübelerinden bahsediyor üniversite
yıllarından bahsediyor Aslında
üniversitede yerde bırakmış bir yandan
çalışıyor Bir Yandan Bir projesi var
onunla ilgileniyor okulun koridorlarında
gezerken sağda solda gördüğü afişlerden
posterlerden Çok etkileniyor
bu afişler
bu afişler kaligrafi ile yani güzel yazı
tekniği ile tasarlanmış olan afişler ve
bu konuda bir eğitim Almaya karar
veriyor bir kursa gidiyor kursta
yazıları öğreniyor Daha doğrusu yazıları
öğreniyor yanlış bir tabir olabilir
yazıların biçimsel özelliklerini
öğreniyor
harflerin yani karakterlerin tırnaklı ve
tırnaksız olarak kullanımını
aralarındaki boşlukları nasıl verilmesi
gerektiğini nasıl bir biçim ve mesaj
karşı tarafa verilebileceğini ve belli
bir alan üzerinde mizanpajını nasıl
yapılabileceğini öğreniyor Aslında
grafik tasarım dersi alıyor
O zamanlar tabii ki bir hobi kendisi
için fakat birkaç sene içerisinde bu iş
artık onun için bir hobi olmaktan
çıkıyor ve bir tutku halinde dönüşüyor
öğrencilerine daha sonra anlatırken de
şu tabiri kullanıyor bilimin
anlayamayacağı bir tarih bir estetik
vardı o yazılarda diye anlatıyor bu
tarih ve estetik meraklısı
delikanlıların ismi ise Steve
Jobs için dünyayı değiştirmiştir Bence
diyen var mı aranızda buna katılan Bu
fikre katılan kaç kişi vardır
Ben bunu savunurum Evet dünyayı
değiştiren insanları insanlardan biri
olduğunu düşünürüm ve bunu tasarımı olan
biçime olan tutkusuyla yaptığını
düşünüyorum her zaman Tutku dememin de
bir sebebi var ufak anlatayım hayatını
anlatan filmlerden bir tanesini bir
sahne var Lisa isimli bir işletim
sisteminin toplantısı sırasında bir anda
teknik konular varken dönüp diyor ki
fontlar nerede
Nasıl ya fontlar nerede bilgisayarda kaç
fonta olacak
kullanıcı kaç farklı değiştirebilecek
deyince mühendislerden bir tanesi Biraz
ters bir cevap veriyor Hafif Türkçe
isteyerek söylemeye çalışayım acı diyor
bantlamakla uğraşacak halimiz yok yani
burada işimiz gücümüz var işletim
sistemiyle uğraşıyoruz deyince çık
dışarı diye adam bu sahne var filmde
izleyebilirsiniz Gerçekte de yaşanmış
bir olay
böyle bir tutkudan bahsediyor ama işte
böyle bir tutku sayesinde
bugün Herhangi bir bilgisayar
programında yazı yazmaya kalktığınız
zaman karşınıza onlarca Belki siz
yüklediyseniz yüzlerce font seçeneğinin
güzel yazı seçeneğinin çıkmasının sebebi
Aslında Steve
şunu diyebilirsiniz ya Böyle bir güzel
yazı takıntısı yeter mi dünyayı
değiştirmeye diyebilirsiniz O zaman ben
de şu kanatları gösterebilirim size
iPhone'a iPhone'da mac'in tuşa
baktığımızda ya da bu cihazlardan sonra
gelen akıllı telefon gibi cihazlara
baktığımızda Aslında Steve jobs'un
tutkusunun imzasını görürüz
ve bunu tasarımla gerçekleştirmiştir
Peki o zaman Tasarım nedir
çok sıfırdan başlayan bir soru gibi
geliyor Gerçekten şöyle izah etmeye
çalışayım ben oldum olası iletişimi çok
seven bir insan olmuşumdur yani
iletişimin içerisinde yer almayı çok
seven biri olmuşumdur hangi şekli olursa
olsun küçükken reklamlar çıkmadan yemek
bile yemezmişim sonra sonra düşününce
Tabi fark ediyorum Bunu reklamlar hem
birer kısa film gibi Aslında sürekli
değişen insanlar mekanlar konular
diyaloglar senaryolar Heyecanlı bir
çocuk için her zaman ama aynı zamanda da
Reklamların içerisinde iletişimin üç
temel yöntemiyle de sürekli olarak şahit
oluyoruz Öyle değil mi Hem görsel hem
yazılı iletişim hem de sözlüyle iletişim
Aslında benim ilgimi çeken buydu
sonra tabii ki bunu keşfettim Nitekim
Yıllar Sonra da Reklamcılık okudum
üniversitede en sevdiğim ders reklam
yazarlığıydı Metin yazarı olmak
istiyordu insanları kelimelerin
varyasyonları ile etkileyebilme ihtimali
beni çok cezbediyordu
derken ikinci sınıfta freehand isminde
bir seçmeli ders aldım Prens isminde bir
program öğrendim bu ders içerisinde bu
bir grafik tasarım programıydı tedaviden
kalkalı çok oldu Tabii ki ne yapıyorsun
Bu programda çok basit araçlar paneli
var kareye tıklıyorsun kare çiziyorsun
yazıya tıklıyorsun yazı yazıyorsun renk
paletinden renk seçiyorsun arka planı
veriyorsun ve biraz önce çekmelerle
yapmayı çok sevdiğimiz söylediğim şeyi
bu sefer imgelerle simgelerle yapabilme
ihtimali benim çok hoşuma gitmişti
Neyse ki üniversiteyi bitirdikten sonra
bir süre sonra da
Kısa bir dönem yazarlığı tecrübe
ettikten sonra grafik tasarımcılık
hayatıma başladım
fakat yine de bir şey eksikti
grafik tasarımcılık yaparken bu sefer
sözlü iletişimle ilgili bir şey
yapamamıştım bu çok dert ediniyordum Ben
kendime mutlaka yapmalıydım böyle bir
şey ne yapabilirdim O zaman bu
Bildiklerimi anlatabilirdim
aktarabilirdin bunun eğitimini
verebilirdin
gittin bir tane kursa bildiğiniz
bilgisayar kursuna bu işleri öğreten
ya da öğrettiğini idare eden bir kursa
gittim dedim ki böyle böyle ben bu işi
yapmak istiyorum hani bunun eğitimi
orientasyonu nasıl olur Nasıl başlar
Nasıl yaparız diye sordum
gel başla dediler yani biraz çabuk oldu
itiraf etmem gerekirse öyle bir şey
olacağını çok beklemiyordum ama bir
şekilde Kendimi orada buldum ve sözel
olarak anlatmaya başladım
ve ilk derslerimden bu yana hep aynı
şeyi söylüyorum bu arada eğitim 4 diye
anlaştık Ben 15 senedir anlatıyor 15
senedir anlatıyorum 4 aylık eğitimi
Tasarım nedir diye başlarım her zaman
tabii ki bu sınıfa gelen insanlar bunu
bilmeyebilirler öğrenmek için buraya
geliyorlar Hiç problem yok bunun doğrusu
da yok Zaten bence ama fikirlerini
öğrenmek isterim
Siz de tasarım gerçekten nedir
bakın Burada çok farklı icatlar var çok
farklı tasarımlar var fikirler var
aslında 3 dolarlık da var 300 milyon
dolarlık da var ama bunların hepsinin
Aslında ortak bir noktası var
bir probleme çözüm getiriyorlar
Herhangi bir problem olabilir ama bir
problemin çözüm fikrini içeriyorlar
Çünkü Açık söylemem gerekirse İnsanoğlu
tırnak içinde tembel bir yaratık
tembelden kastım şu biraz kıvırayım
hemen işimizi kolaylaştırmayı bir
seviyoruz işimizi kolaylaştıralım ki
Keyif aldığımız şeyleri daha çok vakit
ayırabilelim diye
çok sevdiğim bir slogan var bir tatil
acentesinin eskiydi hepimiz tatil yapmak
için çalışıyoruz diye
bu mantıktan bahsediyorum zamanımızı
kendimize ayırmak için bir takım şeyler
yapmayı severiz biz
Ben müziksiz yaşayamam diyen var mı
burada hiç hayatımda müzik çok aktiftir
diye Teşekkür ederim benim için de
öyledir şu teypleri hatırlayan var mı
peki
teyp çalar deniyordu stereoitler
deniyordu Aslında hiphop ve rapi ortaya
çıkaran
icatlardan bir tanesidir ama müzikte
dönüm noktası en büyük icat kabul edilen
şey
Han da budur
ne bu
Walkman ile birlikte artık müzik
kişiselleşiyor ve mobil hale geliyor
Böyle rahatlık var mı
Ben eşimden evime giderken ya da tam
tersi sırasında kulaklıklarından
dilediğim müzikle
kendimi sakinleştirebilirim motive
edebilirim problemlerin üzerine
düşünebilirim ve bunun için sadece
gözümü kapatmam ve Play tuşuna basmam
yeterli çok büyük bir kolaylık insan
için insanın içsel Dünyası için ama
yeter mi insana
abi kaseti çıkar döndür tersini tak
ilerisi var 7 saat dedim ya kolayını
Arıyoruz diye o zaman imdadımıza ne
yetişiyor tasarım yetişiyor yani Yeni
bir fikir yetişiyor Aslında Nedir o disk
mi ya da CD'ler diyebiliriz Bu sefer her
şey daha güzel istediğin şeyler repeat
et istediğin şarkıdan başla biraz daha
kolaylaştı tasarım işimize yaradı talep
ettik bunu
zamanla bu da yetmiyor Tabi ki abi CD'yi
de çıkarmak zorundayım ben istemiyorum
Ben CD'yi çıkarmak istemiyorum
o ona zaman harcamak istemiyorum
içgüdüsel olarak istemiyor o zaman ne
geldi Mp3 çalarlar ve MP3ler hayatımızı
girdi yine tasarımsal bir fikirle
hayatımız bir tık daha kolaylaştı
yetti mi
kesmedi abi bir anda MP3 playerım bir
anda akıllı telefon istemiyorum
ekstra bir yük Benim için o zaman Ne
yapalım akıllı telefonumuzun içine MP3
player'ımızı koyalım Aslında akıllı
telefonlarında çıkış noktası Bir nevi bu
iş daha da kolaylaştı
yetti mi
sizce
yetsin mi peki öyle sorayım belki
yetmedi Evet ben o kadar mp3'ü nereden
bulacağım da indireceğim vakit
harcayacağım da ona Bilgisayarımdan Cep
telefonuma atacağım
O zaman ne geldi çare olarak
Spotify ya da Apple müzik istediğim
yerde istediğim müziği istediğim şekilde
dinleyebilme özgürlüğü Bu arada bu da
yetmeyecek Yani benim örneğim bitti Ama
bizim ihtiyaçlarımız Bitmedi şu anda
çalışmalar işte kulaklığınızı cildinizin
altına yerleştirmek üzerine yapılıyor
daha da kolaylaştırabilmek için işte
aslında Tasarımın yaptığı şey bu tasarım
bir çözüm Fikri sadece kafanızda
herhangi bir şeyin çözümünü düşündüğünüz
zaman
Yiğit ilk konuşmada çok güzel bir söz
söyledi bir sürü güzelse söz söyledi de
bir tanesi oydu kafamda çözmek dedi ya
hani kafanızda çözmeye başladığınız
zaman Aslında tasarım yapıyorsunuz
Çünkü insan sürekli bir ihtiyaç
içerisinde ve bu ihtiyacını karşılamak
için talep ediyor bu talebi tasarım
karşılıyor ve tasarım yeni bir çözüm
oluşturuyor bu yeni çözümde yeni bir
standart bitiriyor hayatımıza ve yeni
ihtiyaçlarımızı doğruyor bu sürekli
dönen bir şey aslında bir daire aslında
bu yüzden
Aynı şeyi tekrar söyleyeceğim tasarım
bir fikir Siz başına ne koyarsanız
onunla ilgili fikirler olur başına
grafik koyarsanız benim alanım o zaman
grafikle ilgili fikirler olur grafik
Graf kelimesinden gelir yazıt demektir
fotoğraf fotograf yani ışıkla yazı
yazmak demektir grafik tasarım size
sadece fotoğraflarla birçok şeyi
anlatabilir birçok mesajı verebilir size
tek bir kelime kullanmadan bir şekerin
ne kadar Diyet ne kadar şekersiz
olduğunu gösterebilir
size bir aracın otomatik park sisteminin
ne kadar ne olduğunu gösteremez çünkü
neyse
size bir kargo şirketinin ne kadar çabuk
çalıştığını gösterebilir Eğer başına
grafik değil de bu sefer endüstri
koyarsanız endüstriyel tasarım
koyarsanız endüstriyel fikirler olur bir
uçağın içine alabilen bir uçak gibi
ya da bütün bir şehrin elektrik
enerjisini karşılayabilen deniz üzerine
yerleştirilmiş güneş panelleri gibi
mimari koyarsanız Eğer mimari tasarım
olur
o zaman yaşadığımız yerlerle ilgili
fikirler olur Şöyle bir bina olsun
gibi
olmasa da olurmuş belki ama en
nihayetinde bir tasarım örneğidir
ya bugün Google Microsoft
Apple gibi ve sayamadığım aklınıza
gelecek ne kadar çok uluslu büyük şirket
varsa birkaç seneden biridir devam
ettirdikleri bir iş geliştirme modelleri
var adı ne biliyor musunuz Dizayn
tinting tasarım odaklı düşünme
işin ilginç tarafı ise şu;
araştırırsanız eğer tasarım odaklı
düşünme yönteminin aslında Sadece
şirketler için olmadığını aynı zamanda
kişiler içinde uygun olduğunu
göreceksiniz çok ciddi kaynaklar var
Türkçesi İngilizcesi yazılısı videosu
ve kendi hayatımızdaki problemleri bile
çok kısa zaman içerisinde çözümü
oluşturabilecek bazı yöntemler içeriyor
Bu yüzden Bence herkes tasarım öğrenmeli
tasarımcı olmak için değil Hayır ama
hayatında karşılaşacağı herhangi bir
problemin çözümü için gerekli
algoritmayı gerekli formülü bulabilmeyi
öğrenmek için Çünkü her seferinde işe
tasarım odaklı düşünmeyi hayatınıza
sokmaya çalışın ufacık bir hikayem daha
var Onu da paylaşmak istiyorum sonra
gideceğim
Mimar Sinan Süleymaniye caminin inşa
ederken düzeltiyorum tasarlarken şöyle
bir fikirle geliyor
caminin kandillerinden ve mumlarından
yükselen izleri
bir odada topluyor
odaya da is odası deniyor baya doğal bir
klimayla hava kanallarından rüzgarı
kullanarak geçirip bu hisleri odada
topluyor sonra bu işler oradan sökülüyor
ve caminin dışında götürülüyor
Osmanlıların hem en önemli ihracat
kalemlerinden biri olan
hem de
nasıl diyeyim en önemli ihracatlerinden
biri olan ism- mürekkebi yapılıyor
bunlarla önce onu söyleyeyim ve ismi
sadece bir ticaret kalemi değil aynı
zamanda
kaligrafi'nin Yani güzel yazının Arap
kökenli versiyonu olan hat sanatının
vazgeçilmez bir malzemesi mürekkep is
mürekkebi çok da değerli bir mürekkep
bir şeyler hatırlattın mı size
konuşuyorum başıyla alakalı kaligrafi
güzel yazı derken
işte belki de
cebimizden
her defasında çıkardığımız günlerde
günde onlarca kere baktığımız cep
telefonlarımızın başına defalarca
oturduğumuz bilgisayarlarımızın
çıkış noktası
fikir noktası
0 noktası
Amerikalı Bir genci etkilediği gibi
belki de Süleymaniye'de tüten
kandillerin hislerinden yükseliyor
olabilir
Ne dersiniz
Bence tasarım olarak düşünmeye
hayatınızı mutlaka eklemeye çalışın
dikkatinizi hesabınız için çok teşekkür
ederim Görüşmek üzere
[Alkış]